Now I had all I've been doing my famous party tree. What I'm going to brother.
Today was my original one by Jane Fonda to Jane Pyle doing today.
Now to get your smug done done done as it then went to always something they didn't know me
but I I done that big number with Johnson's baby had it on my face at politics but just thought yes.
Were any of them were any of the bills that ended up with these photos used to do some of the shows in the social plus
guns as you know it isn't done kind of the devil and all that came out of us to the Germans
and relentless to fearful
and he was soon duty to my knowledge I would be very surprised if edition don't sneak missile that was used in the
ninja Dozier daytime knows a bit about some of the votes and some of the stuff for the been some.
Some of the well the parties of most of these things which but that I'm going to go back to the fifty's.
It was the doing yes well at that time NY.
My knowledge of drag being was totally confined to hearing stories
and only once going to the office pool where Carol when you beat him drifts in and beat dress with Tracy.
The wind in a beat him just increment in the pen take the can G.'s to run and that was all great great great fun too.
What if the year it was the scientists of the soldiers or whatever it was kind and the queen stuff to get bashed
or you don't it will still be obvious full yet squish that sadist softens a what if it was
and they just fade away then this is what it got so I want to know the. Early early early.
This is quite the drag balls like fifty's I think all sixty set was day with the end it was what once a year up it is
sure those girls would see that would be they would come home in that seat here
and they'd be taken for prevail you know sort of thing and that was my first carom is in drag.
They are going to those sort of outfits and still and then be going to those outfits and going to parties in drag
and people getting dressed up to go to parties and dress lace raiding and steroids but you know having you know.
Music is good for the know it's the Queen's improved isn't being good.
I did in the famous stories cabinet apart and meat and the place about utility. Yes I mean there are a lot.
Cindy criminal types and so just sell not substance side as they are and done.
The woman was there with the baby Sunday afternoon putting her to it's usually done by just part of the day we then get
into by good friends a C.
Would put a head in somebody with transit officers they could use you know just I'm just whipped through the day.
Don't ya know I'm something that they used to rape they know I mean
and I remember them writing of a canned fruit of being eighteen especially nineteen coming out of the back fence
and going down the end of events when it starts in St it more. No that was said in the US So where was the bond.
I could loose street you know there was a part of a job. The group cleans the offices of age.
I need to know is what doing stand stays up there was some.
I got at that stage I guess property and it's realized the queens are pretty good tenants except for those days
but if they can get all Queens. You can without with police.
Really acting suspicious of their noise complaints and and you know they wouldn't know the uterus.
By then they'd go once and see the main drag will see that there is a mirror.
I don't know what they arrest them and charge them for I'm not sure.
Lex with that they just arrested them took them to the station Kuntz them up to whatever I don't know what they charged
him for
or if in fact any charges were laid there it is going to the fifty's was a great theory was to lose in the process you
know use his that was a very and he could lose sieges alone.
And as a recast was Mr Justice Minister for sure if they did they charged him.
I'm not I'm not sure what the charge what they did to the people they used to they used to work
but it's very well it's a different kettle of fish like being picked up on a big you could be just a defensive Caviezel
yeah whatever you want to party.
You know I don't like that of course it was like everything in those days we would just points just didn't know
and the place where really that's thirty feet at the day they aren't anymore.
You know when they have somebody sitting on Steven's related again the other night or something
and I still I think that's pretty good i hope more rights happen because the queens are now just getting east of the
place ready.
Instead of being the great shock cause they're just the same as stand out years
and years they've never bothered me is nice to see the other. Stink bombs around town and they do again real gains.
You see little Tyler two for three norms amount of trouble with police writing again and again and again
and again he stopped selling booze but kept writing.
It's a marker for anyone who works in to they just presumed he wasn't shelling out the extra money for the young you
know protection to get Neil Taylor in to the barracks at the same time.
Yes Dylan's of ours and the other players there with no licenses.
Yeah well he hasn't got any of those losses you know what I mean is if you've got somebody who's operating on those
levels if they don't pay for that
or was a great young as well if they just know that the combination is yes yes I think that would be like I just think
that's a bit of beeches arithmetic said that they were down on the state does that I do.
I doubt that any steam about these money if you put Leigh careen Yes fun. Yes that's true that's different.
Yes but if you don't have makeup.
I do doubt that any of them pay on a bus level with just you're a person
when I was in the parking spots to yeah it would be easy to but not of the knights
and to the civil carry stuff that was the second step. Yes the storms of the games.
I started that are going to be seen through the course of this because I just get so sick again as we should do nothing
really to most of the next ten trying to do this I could see how much money was being made
and you know you just need a plane there. Asheville is just go go go. And I can read it can absolutely. And you know.
And fortunately the brand with the. So wasteful. It was too far and it wasn't well done and if it's case.
Well it was a very big lesson and fortunately at that time I was able to negotiate to buy that building
and having bought that building. You're insane. It's wrong and I was able to read The Lord Mayor. You know his name.
It wasn't a good. There's no no and no name and straight.
Yeah yeah yeah that's it really say here
and what they were quite aware of what was over they just what they were what they inject into it went through trust
but objected to on the grounds that there was no parking facilities here.
And finally I went to him
and say look I'm conducting a business in your municipality all I'm doing it is moving it from one six into another you
can all children hold me up I said I hope that building.
I'm ready to go even use it in the past so you really haven't read what's going on and on the Net Not much.
Now it was you know he says he even said to me it would be nearly seventy two
or late seventy one that I didn't because I was there for about a year and then I came down
and we actually came down here this was still running as the book on the net had been derelict for us to be
and this is why I know was I able to get it through because he pointed out that this guarantee building that was being
inhabited by drunks and their things sending if you buddy.
While I was prepared to do something with that and that's how we actually got through it. I wasn't there.
The comedian didn't understand that's it and I said no no no it's it's like it's always had a dreadful repeated.
As a kind of sexual home.
I understand in the nation from a professor of you know this duty stuff was called Radcliffe who lives around his son
and he's always done that about you from time to time that I just retired I think in the last two years at phoning
myself like you know people think this is just wonderful.
Well we know he's not we don't isolate the outside world for the Yes You know nothing father anybody who's a face would
just think they didn't they knew everything couldn't be all you could get a council meeting saying
and Professor read from the University of New South Wales gathered up that this hideous place seniors attracting our
young people and you know things like when you do whatever they thought you going to claim holds up for the company.
I suppose to all intents
and purposes see to get into rand week at Rand week I had taken out a legitimate health studio that's the only way I
could get it. I suppose I feel studio. That was already established as a studio here but it's like you.
They've made it there. You're just transferring is just existing operating a studio.
Then it was free from the film going to whoever would find out about it about what if what they never found out
and ran because they would never be transferred and I don't know how they got a buck when they were robbed on Monday
and the detective came in just in what you already have some cases like that's where it's gone to see what your point
here but I remember I witnessed it five years ago I would say to Steve driver.
You know and you know the work I think we did that I never did that there either. It changes with weights.
I don't just said you know but he just called that really is to say oh you know even lots of good people.
This is a bunch of guy who is at the end I was very lucky to be out here in Kensington because of the three of us to
see his days as to what it is. It'll be but I think I may be lucky as a city in this case on Monday.
I think is different. Somebody with you and I I don't employ straight.
It's a little soft and you think that was the best time and they got into a German boy called down on son Chance
and showed us what you can do you think you know as well as not
and so we don't know what we're supposed to sing like in the fifty's and in those three huge cuts.
It would have been Wilson Yes the ricks was the highlight place that was with the rock
when I was eighteen I didn't sort of know that camp until I was eighteen and somebody picked me up
and took me up to do it just to that stage I was the only eighteen year old in there with little
and went up to the Greeks and it was off to the rate she would by the bottles of booze
and go to the pound Chiles Black was about his days
and he would sort of say that he's just he's mother father the way he says you can't say that you were black
or anything.
Well can they you know a story becomes a vacuum that's just going to get around in the kids
and it is going to be because it's a very it's going to give a sense of the rights of the place where we will go say.
And you're like my father that he was easy going to then he had everybody under russian their beaks hottest goals
slamming him taxis would be you know that was with apologies.
In fact you never in the fifty's identi gave an organized party because she just needed everybody says yes that's right
and you need to organize the party in your own place because she just knew that it would be up to fix in ten minutes
and you could expect the only time that they had hockey is I think the parties that I've been to were sort of like long
weekends where you eat all the way down to Newport and it was it rented cottage and all that interposed.
Is this idea of what we did but I think they would Rickson rage or whatever their names were on the station
but just we went to the ice to get instant in your hotel then it was called the centennial
and Bruce form of would be playing there and lined up to say listen to the rough numbers
and we used to have wildly hole their tempi and they used to hot he used to hog the whole day they listen.
Is that you know they all the talking.
Oh I was so yeah just Sinton then and they all used to get back there
and Bruce would take the band back to their land and would cost a treat.
I was getting that was where Office came in contact again we rough a numbers where up until then I had no concept that
square now this would get off if you know all that it's we know this would be attractive to news.
The next step up from the day when criminals will say this
or whatever they would that push the next step up was the drag queen syndrome where those tough little boys from
Paddington needed to do things
and from then on square trade's just being sort of I thought a little bit as if their luck that it got seeps through to
the queen's that just because they persuade didn't mean they wouldn't be so I don't know.
We'll see this from my mother who works at two five three says nearly thirty defeats regular KLEIN You know her
sexually married me who you know I don't like coming here for dates so old guy six run.
So there's a bonus points for the people who use six Lot guy six lives you've done the work in Michael's part secrecy
and Yes Well it's nice to think that Steve does not always film that is there for the smoothness of having to get all
your receiving which suppose for most of the rest of the most of the books is in the east
and so was this that loosens up so let's study at the start.
It's more countries to try to he makes a point that most of the guys doing stuff with their strike
or heterosexual here and he was clever about he and someone else they sat outside
and took a number plate to the cause of it
when there's a kind of encrypted light wrongly for to their children best to go to the government it's kind of that
they didn't attend the retreat this together because he was a sociologist of university
and they were doing the whole study that was doing this. No study of me.
You're just here to tell the addresses and shove them in as well.
I didn't have nothing to do with the study
but it was a way of getting find out you know that you know the fact is situations it's always been there was a huge
drop out there then was everybody did afterwards going to the gun interview always played with the Course to go to
digest to get a bit of being such a gentleman here. It was a huge row about it because people said he was.
What is he doing at Humphrey's because it really is wonderful books I used to go into the toilets of course I'd stand
at the door
and just watch because it was always somebody if it was just me from the police would I see a store stand
and just this is my story and there are one point where he got a risk to stand up to the standing watches
and the police took him back to the police station and he's and something
or another he got all these you know just me
and he said I'd like you to call my wife I'm going to come down the aisle and they say
but because he was you know it was a freak the place up tight with a sign you know get the wife down a year ago she
knew exactly what he was doing well I don't know that she did because it was about five is after that that he did this
is a here in volume I have not had to do doing research.
So that's why I was hanging around to be sure
but I don't think I think in truth that he was good enough governance I mean I just this raised a badly kind played on
news.
You know you didn't take that piece of roots down I'm not questioning if we were discussing us like James face facts.
Does he run
and beat was an apprentice at Down Yonder he deceived him it was an apprentice at the sun here we're going to think it
and then it was it printed at the whatever that thing is and he said during the strike. Sue in the first place.
Yes at during the strikes those boys always sleep there and James used to come down
and I said Well no I don't believe that's just friendship testing Genesis to show that that I think we Gentry's always
advisable as whatever he was managing director of Fairfax to be talked to on the editorial lines was
or no human policy.
Yes I've only met him once I was I was introduced in the trade rather for trade back in seventy two
and he well he was managing director of it but.
He used to talk about Sid No I didn't describe the rest of the job of checking up about reducing what I printed which I
said was nothing that he said oh no that's not true and I said Look.
OK you got shipped with ivory because you got a lot of the things I missed so he went to the trouble of taking these
like the writing that C.G.
Did drugs and since then I've corresponded to the point where if I send letters in that they don't get published.
I usually send the copy of it in the eyes of the I'll just drop even though it's a good thing still out of hearing you
know but you know yes in the end he just you know the issue of those who sort of kept in touch to that one.
I've been waiting to go back and have another talk to people is the situation really was getting ludicrous.
But of course in the last year or so the Herald is finally cracked and is is running stuff for us
but we all got to talk to them because with these bill comes back up to the next election.
Our years see the times come
and I see that considered seriously their will to run for president of the ordeal at the crucial time
and we'll talk about it. Yes. It cannot deny. I was telling DADE I don't mean it.
James he would know the people I mean
and I have been around in that situation in connection with that line that always at the time he gave me the impression
that he was a approachable about things like He's very shy as you know
and very charming as far as meeting people on a personal scale is going to consent
but I always felt that he really was prepared to stick around and be within the Herald in the editorial section
or in the political I don't know that he is I think what.
Not to shut you up
or think what Susie's he's been doing since each of those which is not so he said as managing director is he's been
busy moving the and apart from the fact that fortunately a number of people who were very much.
The problem for the other indices for have got areas of all retarded in that period
and he's deliberately been moving in much more liberal people I see Novick Carroll who's now the issues of X.
Such as assume it's Ritchie for the whole group
and he's been deliberately bringing in much more liberal they will see the whole paper has changed
and I think he's going to be that way rather than what gets us out of the managing director and you'll do the.
This is what I'm doing everything was right and they don't do that. I see it's feels like it means.
Whereas I don't think James. I mean I don't know I didn't get a feel.
I would ask those times will be most likely because most newspaper writers are on any issue very lies to move in
and say this this and this must be written so you can try and put in people who they can trust
and then give them that degree because that's the whole truth that they're all about
and I think he's trying to do it that way so it probably get told to him a balanced
but the upshot of that may be Carol you know it's good.
Yes I see we're in a dead heat make that Carol connection and then ranking up to it
and saying I was just speaking to all of me will be that I can go and talk to James and he
and he would say you know I don't mind I'm going to go into town or why don't you go
and talk to exude makes such will Carol.
If he comes up on a mission of but I'm not going to go and
or he probably would tell me how he's in the few months to do it.
He knows another thing
but he made the background sufficiently And have you gotten this Is there anything else you want to ask me on that
because I'd like to ask you about the status of the because another of the knowledge here. Is there a bit.